salut juste avant que la vidéo ne
commence je fais ce petit rajout pour
vous informer que loïc cadre mais vidéo
et qui monte vous le connaissez vient de
sortir son court métrage pour le nikon
film festival
ça s'appelle je suis pressé je vous met
à lire dans la description alors moi
j'avais eu la petite idée de base mais
c'est lui qui a écrit ce scénario qu'a
réalisé qu'à tout fait évidemment c'est
son film à lui voilà allez voir ça
allait check et j'espère que ça vous
plaira profitez-en pour voir les autres
films il ya plein de petites pépites sur
ces nikon c'est très très cool d'aller
farfouiller là dessus et moi je vous
laisse avec la vidéo à très bientôt
lumières moteur casse tête tu vas adorer
cette nouvelle intro loïc elle est pour
toi c'est une dédicace que quelqu un ami
je trouve qu'il ya un manque de
luminosité du coup prochain intro
lumière moteur casse tête
est ce que tu pourrais expliquer en
commentaire quel est le problème de
luminosité que certains ont parfois
[Musique]
merci pour la première fois sur cette
chaîne il y à la suite d'un casse tête
que j'ai pas pu finir en une seule fois
alors résumé de l'épisode précédent
nous avons fait une descente aux enfers
avec le début du binaire oui ultime
nous avons ouvert une chaîne secondaire
fabien arrow post-it master on sera
bientôt cent mille d'ici cent mille
abonnés en fait on a propulsé une chaîne
de lapin on a fait tout ça et maintenant
il faut continuer à le faire et on est
dans un état tel que loïc abandonné le
cadre si c'est fou c'est loïc ne veut
plus tu veux plus voir ce casse-tête
loïc unis tiens ma santé mentale
ok alors c'est parti stylo post-it les
abonnés de fabien rofes master savent
d'ailleurs si vous voulez la prochaine
vidéo avec le post-it orange n'hésitez
pas à me le faire savoir dans les
commentaires de cette vidéo et avant que
je devienne complètement fou rappelez
vous que je serai le 9 janvier en
dédicace au cultura de mondeville le 16
janvier en spectacle à hier au casino le
19 janvier en spectacle à l'espace
julien à marseille le 26 janvier au
centre culturel de buts mais c'est
complet déjà et le 27 janvier un coup de
carte blanche et puis après bordeaux
ribeauville saint-etienne c'est complet
venez ça fait plaisir c'est reparti je
suis dégoûté de voir le reprendre je le
jure j'adore mais en même temps je le
déteste j'ai pas envie de commencer
qu'en maintenant j'ai d'autres choses à
faire après dans la journée donc il faut
quand même que je sens l'envi de vomir
monter en moi
mme alexeeva
[Musique]
je sais que la vie elle était ici arrêté
ou à l'etrat si elle était là ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on va la faire
passer là donc lui il faut l'orienter
complètement là ça veut dire que si ma
mémoire est bonne et elle les germes
avait créé des vip sur ce sujet et ça
veut dire qu'il faut faire deux crans et
pour faire deux crans il faut tapoter
deux fois et donc il faut pouvoir
on sait ça et donc pour le pousser il
faut que j'ai ici aura c'est reparti sur
les post it 1 1 les amateurs de post it
se régale sur cette chaîne
oh oh pourquoi pas où on peut faire que
du hockey pour le monter en haut avait
sinon eh ben c'est tchèque [ __ ] ça va
à une vitesse incroyable
lui il est pas du tout en haut alors
pour le monter t'avoue que je reprenne
le rythme je sais qu le oui d'accord ok
très bas ça c'est ça ça va
et lui en aussi ça veut dire fait je
dois en fait un
comme on dit dans le jargon ntm ni non
c'est pas ça cntm ça veut dire nettoie
ton micro si longtemps pas mal j'avais
pas vu que lui
l'huile à celui ci ils bloquent en fait
lui il doit être en bas on intègre un
cinquième est donc je pense qu'après on
va voir si cette v et oui on va tous les
avoirs après en fa la la ça va prendre
une plombe mon gars tu nous y aurait
acquis bleu klein qu'est ce que je fous
d'accord il y avait rien qui bloquait
voyez ma voix rauque et la guerre mme
dati ne m'a jamais beau je ne comprends
plus je moi je ne comprends plus moi
même nous faudrait une montée maintenant
nouveau ça fera loïc ça me saoule déjà
battu ricane parce que j'aime c'est la
virilité de tangue mais qu'il faut se
maquaient bouffe
ab je bougeais d'un migrant es ça fait
plaisir un de regarder des casse tête le
matin ça c'est quelque chose qu'on me
connaît c'est quelque chose qu'on
maîtrise fait rien on a vu ça à
l'entraînement on peut le faire on peut
le réaliser en quelques news comme ceci
parce que vraiment les casse-têtes c'est
la vie les casse tête c'est l'amour les
castels c'est la joie
donc il est descendu toi il faut que je
te mettant en garde alors ça te mettre
en å vraiment tu crois que c'est un
problème est ce que tu as vu la vidéo de
la semaine dernière mon gars c'est pas
un problème d'autres mettant hockey amh
et non un si c'était bien de le
descendre
[ __ ] fabien site à l'ul ce que tu fais
ou un modèle je te parle plus ce qui
fait quoi ce qui fait que tu seras tout
seul dans ta tête c'est ça que tu veux
mais non de continuer à voir des amis
imaginaires dans ton cerveau alors tu
fais ce que je te dis pour aller tout
droit dessus là qui me bloque à ya que
lui qui bloque la version censée faire
ça hop voilà
[Musique]
vous parle plus trop ce que au final
quand je réfléchis jamais dit que tout
ça c'est à cause de vous vous envoie un
peu dans son ce que je sais que
maintenant si je le finis pas quelque
chose qui il n'y aura pas entre nous
alors un peu comme si vous m'obligez à
faire ça moi est ce qu est ce que c'est
ça que j'avais connu dans ma vie au
suivant
revenons vers moi là je dis quoi se dit
long jean-jacques comme maintenant il
faudrait que je remonte lui on en est
vraiment la lega et s'étant accélérée
c'est moi qui vais super meat là chaque
jeu c'est pas logique c'est au montage
tu vas t'en sortir tellement gelé big
c'est n'avait l'air dans mes cheveux
je ne sais pas exactement pourquoi je
fais ça mes bras durant une fraction de
seconde j'ai su pourquoi je le faisais
alors je termine de faire un là là et
maintenant il faut continuer à faire ce
chemin là la fin de la suite ah mais
c'est horrible
maintenant je leur ai tout à gauche donc
il va bloquer comme d'habitude c'est
jean-jacques jean jacques gilet jaune
toujours en train de croquer aux fuites
en mer de port sont comme d'habitude je
mixe et des chansons de pop car sans ce
qui me gêne qui me gêne c'est qu'il gêne
à wau pas forcément bah oui eh ben oui
c'est bel et bien le seul
je serai là bruges pour faire des
limitations siens et vous souvenez on
n'a pas parlé qu'au départ il fallait
que ce soit aux os et aux bas bon il est
en bas donc lhi maintenant tout de le
rectifier en donc pour le remonter en
fait c'est vraiment ça le truc c'est
qu'il faut aller de bas vers le haut
dans la construction pour le déplacement
de la vie également de droite vers la
gauche dans chaque ligne qu'on résout
pour passer à la ligne suivante
mais à chaque fois ça nous rajoute une
étape en plus qui va impacter tout ce
qui a déjà été fait et comme dans
remontée lui la de cette ligne là le
premier qui va m'embêter c'est lui donc
il faut d'abord que je m'occupe de lui
pour m'occuper du reste pour ensuite
m'occuper lui m'occuper du reste et
m'occuper de lui m'occuper du reste à la
leaf a bien rendu 3d on y croit on a
envie de faire cette cinquième étape
quand même
2 3 4 5 un peu gable juge pas et on a
une jauge là je laisse en juger mais
sans juger fabien olicard le prince deux
sont jugés tallard s est dit à l'ats
restent à l'arrêt à qui sait plus
pourquoi il fait ça
voilà quand je commence à parler de moi
à la troisième personne on n'est pas bon
cette pologne 19 h à g se convergent
vêtements à gauche mehiaoui qui blacks
et un wiki bhl faut le mettre en pot
pour mettre l'autre complètement à
gauche complètement fou pour traitement
à go go go go go go lui remettant au bar
oui on n'a pas le choix
eux oui on est en train de remonter
d'accord on souvient ça me rappelle
vraiment dans les douze travaux
d'astérix et doivent perdre si le
formulaire là
de ramener le certificat ou les guerres
les mais pareil je galère et je deviens
fou on va réveiller ça ça c'est la
figure qu'on veut pour la cinquième je
vais donc 1,5 entouré ça fait ça fait
est non ça fait ou oraux au haut haut
bas haut bas le bas est en bas tchèque
le pot et dans aux tchèques
le haut et en tchèque le haut ou bas
tchèque
ça devrait pas être le plus dur en toi
ça c'est vraiment tout ce que vous venez
de voir depuis le début de cette vidéo
c'était pour faire ça on aime ou pas
est-ce qu'on aime notre vie
bref on n'est pas fou mais un sondage
répondez it ok google quelle heure est
il c'est bien on a commencé à 9h à l'eau
c'est marrant si c'était un feutre à
l'eau
[Musique]
berciaud nam il est à peut-être pour
vous aussi parce que je sais pas combien
de temps va faire cette vidéo
après une journée complète sur le casse
tête non c'est pas pris quelques heures
l'après midi c'est une journée complète
chose que je n'avais pas anticipé clic
est logique après coup un à chaque fois
qu'on augmente un petit peu ça devient
exponentielle
je vais aller au bout de ma vie vu la
neige tombée le printemps revenir tue
les gens partis en vacances l'été
l'automne passé et me voici de nouveau
en hiver bref je termine la vidéo il est
tard et j'ai commencé il faisait nuit
je termine et il sait de croix qui sera
la première vidéo de 2019 vous souhaite
une bonne année ceux qui sont encore là
et peut-être la dernière vidéo de 2019
c'est possible qu'ils aient encore la
dite moi dans les commentaires c'est
même plus comment finir alors il ya un
parti une partie de roche qui sera même
plus là puisque loïc s'est barré normale
et que la presse a coupé y ait plus de
batterie mais moi je m'en soucier plus
on était quand même pas loin de d'un
abandon ou d'une mort
j'avais très cérébral comme ça y'a qu'à
un moment donné même plus je parlais
l'espèce de mutisme
donc si tout va bien je fais enfin le
dernier mouvement en avant dernier et du
coup il faut que je présente la vie
regardez regardez on peut enfin de
déplacés lui le monter la bille est
présenté on peut même pas sortir
je ne sais pas si vous voyez en fait le
trophée que l'habit ne peut même pas
sortir
elle peut pas elle peut pas sortir c'est
vraiment futin et sans déconner tout ça
pour que la bielle sortent pas au final
mais c'est un scandale c'est et puis ça
c'est quoi c'est pour faire un
porte-clés vous croyez que je vais le
garder alors je vous le prix gagnés sur
instagram et c'est à vous de le remettre
dans le bon sens un casse tête bien fini
c'est un casse tête qui va dans les deux
sens vers mettez le dans le bon sens et
je vous inviterai sur la chaîne la
personne qui gagne le truc qu'il remet
dans le bon sens je l'invite sur la
chaîne je lui offre la chaîne fabien arp
au type master voilà ce que je fais bike
et la vidéo abonnez vous à cette chaîne
abonnez vous au moins dans la rue vous
menez vous ne cherchez vous abonner
directement sur moi vous mettez un cri à
la papier la poche copie de votre pièce
d'identité ça vous à bonn
automatiquement ici je vous mets la
suite des vidéos des lapins ici je vous
mets la suite de chez pas quoi on va
dire que c'était la vidéo 0,2 cette
année la vraie vidéo sortira samedi
prochain voilà ce à quoi je montrais un
kinder surprise
avoirs pei coupé